[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sont des images de l'avenir que nous
a apporté cette semaine la chèvre
nantais cnic de la première centrale
nucléaire française et des f1 sur le
territoire de la petite commune d'avoine
près de chinon a dévoilé le spectacle
des centrales électriques de l'âge
atomique
[Musique]
dès l'été prochain la sphère d'acier de
55 mètres de diamètre qui renfermera et
des f1 s'inscrira dans le paysage à côté
des parallélépipèdes de béton de et des
f2 et premiers kilowatts d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire partiront vers le
réseau de distribution à chinon ce
jour-là l'atome commencera à prendre la
relève des grands barrages et de leurs
usines hydroélectriques
[Musique]
aux états unis les images de l'avenir
c'est au chimpanzé et nosc on les doit
héros de la répétition générale du
voyage de l'homme américain autour de la
terre et nasa a été confiée dans une
capsule mercury à une fusée atlas
il me devait effectuer trois rotations
afin d'être récupérés
il n'en effectué a que deux d'ailleurs
parfaitement réussie pour la plus grande
satisfaction du lieutenant colonel klein
à droite désigné pour le premier vol
humain et son éventuel remplaçant scott
carpenter
[Musique]
et nasa a été récupéré en plein
atlantique d'où on l'expédié à passer
une sérieuse visite médicale
et ne s'y mettra bien vivant mais l'oeil
un peu triste il est vrai qu'on serait
abattu à moi
[Musique]
il ne faut pas trop se fier à cette
courtoisie réciproque du japonais
collisionner et du hollandais guessing
dans un instant ils vont totalement
oublier toutes ces politesses et alors
ils vont parler le langage des judokas
un langage qui se traduit par toutes
sortes de figures au nom bizarre mais
comme nous ne connaissons pas le
japonais ben non nous a regardé le
pendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
tout ceci se termine par la victoire
inattendue du hollandais qui devient
champion du monde avant d'affronter ses
supporteurs beaucoup plus dangereux
semble-t-il que le japonais
[Applaudissements]
vingt mille stéphanois pour assister à
la résurrection de juste pantene le
numéro 8 du stade de reims maillot
français en mangent blanc ce numéro 8
c'est celui qui le porte est en suède il
ya trois ans alors qu'il était le
meilleur shooteur de la coupe du monde
depuis il s'est cassé deux fois la jambe
à propos de cette jambe un énorme point
d'interrogation
la réponse elle est simple regardez vous
même excellente passe aux partenaires
démarqués et ses miracles que reims ne
soient pas parvenus là à réussir un but
[Applaudissements]
cette action favorable rémois ne doit
pas faire illusion c'est saint-etienne
qui a dominé durant les trois quarts de
la partie domination qui se traduit par
un premier but
et comme les stéphanois ont continué de
surplace et leurs adversaires ils ont
marqué un second but résultat reims
n'est plus en tête du championnat
[Applaudissements]
sans doute les coupables ont expliqué
leurs crimes sans doute un jour de 1946
l'amiral tojo et ses complices ont été
condamnés à la mort des criminels mais
il reste que rarement pareil attentats
ne fut tentée et réussie à l'aube du 7
décembre voici vingt ans sans
déclaration de guerre
361 avions s'envolèrent de porte-avions
qui sans être découvert s'était approché
de la grande base navale américaine du
pacifique
pearl harbour
[Musique]
quinze minutes suffirent pour réduire à
néant la plus belle et ce cadre du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce fut sans doute le plus fulgurant
désastre navale de tous les temps 5
cuirassé détruits ou coup les trois
ravagé par l'incendié un grand nombre de
croiseurs et de destroyers détruit 3500
morts prix de l'impréparation et de
l'insouciance
se souvient temps de pearl harbour
[Musique]
elle
l'évocation au louvre de l'atelier de
georges braque dans le prix que le monde
attache à cette artiste il est le
premier peintre vivant a exposé au
louvre cette reconstitution situe mieux
que toutes les études l'univers d'où le
peintre a tiré sa magie personnel
c'est ce compte inaugurer ensemble
monsieur andré malraux et l'artiste lui
même avec les quelques soixante toiles
qui forme non pas une rétrospective mais
bien un regroupement où s'offrent la
continuité d'une inspiration transfigura
trice le georges braque du louvre n'est
en effet pas différent du georges braque
que nous filmions dans sa retraite de
varengeville voici quinze ans et qui
poursuivait dans le silence cette
opération de mise en forme poétique des
objets quotidiens sous le signe d'un
cubisme élargi aux limites du songe
poétique
[Musique]
quel est dans l'art de notre temps la
place de georges braque ses notes sourde
de lumière qui illumine son oeuvre cette
reconversion des choses habituelles et
leur métamorphose poétique éclipse bien
des renommées tapageuse
saluons l'entrée au louvre d'un grand
peintre contemporain
[Musique]
en inaugurant devant le premier char à
banc à moteur l'exposition le siècle de
l'automobile le ministre du commerce et
de l'industrie avait avant toute chose à
rendre hommage à l'audacieux chercheurs
qui imagina un moteur ou le foyer serait
logée dans un cylindre l'inventeur
etienne le noir se flattait de supprimer
ainsi la chaudière organes encombrants
et dangereux les résultats de vente
encourageant quand on s'avise à
d'employés à combustible gazeux ainsi en
1861 acquis le moteur à explosion
l'automobile suivies dès 1891 la
construction série s'était emparé de
l'auto et les routes de campagne purent
admirer les modèles super chic du double
fight on chasse ibra ferrer allumage par
brûlures frein sur les bandages des
roues arrière et des qui pour empêcher
de dérivés on pouvait atteindre le 25 à
l'heure en 1895 l'utilisation du premier
pneu donner un nouvel essor à la voiture
et léon bollée présentait un tricycle
dont les 30 km/heure faisait trembler
les cyclistes en 1902 l'automobile
prenait du galon avec la course paris
vienne la première grande épreuve de
vitesse que gagner marcel renaud
avec les premier tour de france cycliste
l'automobile avait pris ses lettres de
noblesse la caravane suiveuse déjà été
automobile
[Musique]
le consort gagner des points l'élégance
sans elle est portée à voile est
charmant cache poussière et l'ondulé
premier embouteillage
1904 marqua une grande date si paris n'a
drid s'arrêta à bordeaux on y était allé
à cent à l'heure ce furent les premiers
marty
[Musique]
l'automobile entré dans les moeurs
l'attelage à la dom on faisait place
sous le règne de monsieur phal hier aux
40 cheveux sous capot
elle entrait aussi dans les mauvaises
moeurs la bande à bonnot fut son
initiatrice précurseur de tous les
gangsters en voiture bono dès 1911 fille
de l'auto l'auxiliaire essentiel si
banal aujourd'hui de toutes les
agressions
[Musique]
la guerre de 14 devait tenir à l'auto le
lustre de la gloire guerrière et taxis
de paris sont peut être les vrais
vainqueurs de la bataille de la marne
[Applaudissements]
la paire en à l'automobile à des
compétitions pacifique et avec ses
voitures à chenilles la croisière noire
traversait le savent
[Musique]
les premières voitures de course
apparurent sur le circuit de la sarthe
vous devez sortir un peu plus tard les
24 heures du mans
[Musique]
1940 supprima à paris la circulation
automobile mais on vit naître cette
électrique qui semblait dire patience
automobile panneaux et nous en sommes
venus à cette merveille de mécanique que
prévoyait peut-être etienne le noir le
précurseur mais avaient ils prévu un
succès si total ces milliers de voitures
si parfaite qu'elle ne peuvent plus
faire que du 4 à l'heure
[Musique]
ge de la réhabilitation pour l'équipe de
france de football qui note blanche
contre l'équipe d'espagne à colombes
devant 50000 spectateurs en 90 minutes
cette équipe a retrouvé élan et
dynamisme il ne lui manque qu'une chose
un peu de personnes depuis que marc
françois ott numéro 10 après s'y être
reprise à 3 fois illustre assez bien là
peu près qui marque la fin de la plupart
des deux principes face à
l'espanyol trento numéro 11 qui a
tendance à confondre course à pied
football créée ici une fois n'est pas
coutume une situation dangereuse pour
l'équipe de france
de fait les vedettes du real madrid 10
et stephano en tête numéro 9 n'ont
convaincu personne et le but
d'égalisation que marc l'espagne est
entaché d'un hors-jeu flagrant que n'a
pas vu la vitre il est vrai qu arbitre
n'a pas vu grand chose au cours de ce
match
les avants français ont tout de même
donné une fois le grand frisson aux
spectateurs des tribunes sur cette
attaque
cinquante mille spectateurs debout crois
qu'elle va faire mouche
et bien non maintenue pour les deux
équipes
à son retour à elisabethville know is
shown des présidents de la république
katangaise a pu entendre crépiter les
mitrailleuses dans la capitale en effet
c'est la guerre une guerre de rue qui
oppose des troupes katangaise aux
casques bleus de l'onu passé à
l'offensive
guerre sainte jusqu'à l'éviction des
troupes de l'onu a proclamé le
gouvernement qu'attendait guerre totale
contre le katanga a affirmé le
secrétaire de l'onu
et à elisabethville chaque jour il y a
des morts et des blessés
à bruxelles ces événements ont provoqué
une manifestation de réprobation contre
les nations unies arborant des slogans
dénués d'aménité les manifestants ont
conspué l'organisation internationale
à paris les ministres des affaires
étrangères de grande-bretagne et des
etats-unis d'allemagne de france se sont
trouvés au quai d'orsay entretien 4 qui
avait ouvert une grande semaine
diplomatique celle ci devait en effet
voir se réunir également dans la
capitale française les 6 du marché
commun et les 15 de l'otan
[Musique]
devant le buste que neuilly sur seine a
dédié à jean mermoz un groupe est venu
saluer cette grande figure de l'aviation
qui disparu il ya exactement 25 ans au
dessus de l'atlantique
guidera cavaillès était là vieux
compagnons de la grande aventure j'en
ernaux était l'homme qui pour la
première fois avait traversé
l'atlantique sud son exploit paris-dakar
natale buenos aires et retour à bord de
la foncière avait déchaîné
l'enthousiasmé et paris lui avait fait
après sa double traversée une sorte de
trion c'est que l'exploit avec une
signification plus haute qu'un beau
geste sportif il ouvrait à l'aviation un
domaine jusqu'ici inviolée et inauguré
la ligne commerciale qui de toulouse par
casa dakar natale et buenos aires
monnaie jusqu'à santiago du chili
le 7 décembre 1936 à bord de la croix du
sud jean mermoz partait pour sa 24e
traversée au large de dakar ont perdu sa
trace le sait on n'a jamais rien rendu
mais jean mermoz était entré à la fois
dans l'histoire et dans la légende
[Applaudissements]
région pacifique le relief africain et
pour finir la terre toute entière c'est
ce qu'avait au pot de ces deux rotations
autour de notre planète et 900 ch à
penser ou plutôt la caméra automatique
qui l'accompagnait le mouvement de
rotation du globe est ici 50 fois plus
rapide que dans la réalité
[Musique]
un document qui sera sans doute vite
dépassé les un document qui fixe une
étape un document qu en somme dans cent
ans on regardera avec une certaine
condescendance peut-être mais non sans
doute sans attendrissement
[Musique]
jean delannoy a joué les père noël avant
la lettre en remettant à renée marie
potet au nom des auteurs de films le
prix suzanne bianchetti qui récompense
les brillants débuts d'une jeune
comédienne est raide pradier et chic à
jour où et quelques autres lauréates des
années passées étaient venus saluer
cette nouvelle venue dans le champ des
étoiles
le temps n'est plus où la coiffure
s'improvisait dans un salon de quartier
elle possède aujourd'hui c'est utile ces
laboratoires tels à aulnay sous bois
près de paris
les plus grands laboratoires capillaire
d'europe
c'est là que journaliste et spécialiste
de la beauté féminine sont venus
assister à la première de modeling
nouvelles techniques de la coiffure
qu'alexandre et jacques dessange met
aujourd'hui en pratique
une ligne on s'en doute que l'histoire
de la coiffure moderne ne date que de
1882 avec l'apparition de l'ondulation
l'un des frises à bhl ne date que du
début de ce siècle et l'on en était
encore aujourd'hui à hésiter entre la
permanente durable et la mise en plis
sans permanente mais éphémère désormais
les coiffures souple et naturel dureront
plus longtemps et chaque femme se
rassurent coiffée avec la plus grande
facilité
[Musique]
ma jing une nouveauté qui prend dans le
domaine de la mode une allure de
révolution
[Applaudissements]
la banderole en indre et loire est
aujourd'hui un nom d'espoir à l'orée
d'un bois de chêne a été créé le premier
centre destiné non seulement à la
désintoxication mais aussi à la
réadaptation des malades alcooliques
l'originalité de la cure de la membrolle
est en effet d'associer le traitement
psychologique coloré de contacts humains
au traitement physiologique classique à
base de pilules des spirales provoquant
le dégoût de l'alcool
à cet effet le centre ne se présente pas
comme un simple établissement
hospitalier il met à profit avec une
salle de spectacle et une bibliothèque
un vaste atelier en un mot un cadre
adapté à de multiples activités
professionnelles ou récréatives dont le
but est d'assurer la réadaptation à la
vie collective voire la promotion
sociale guéri et réadapter le malade
sera par la suite suivi pour la cure
d'entretien par un dispensaire d'ores et
déjà 150 cas traités sont là pour
témoigner en faveur de cette méthode
nouvelle 150 alcoolique délivrés de leur
esclavage
[Musique]
se souvient ton de landru dont les
exploits en pire la presse voici 40 ans
c'est en 1919 que le petit journal dans
un district entrefilet annonce à
l'arrestation d'un certain andru pour
d'obscurs histoire de disparition on
avait arrêté un matin dans l'appartement
de montmartre où il habitait sous le nom
de guillet il devait aussi plus tard
outre différents noms portés celui de
barbe bleue et la presse publie à cette
mauvaise photo qui devaient rendre une
barbe sellette car la sphère de jour en
jour prenait une extension imprévus ont
compté jusqu'à 11 personnes que la
fréquentation de landru semblait avoir
mystérieusement retirés de la
circulation de la attention au crime il
n'y avait qu'un pas il fut franchi
allègrement procéder d'une simplicité
enfantine les petites annonces
matrimoniales drainer vers landru le
trouble sentimentale d existence
solitaire la faire se nouait à la gare
et souci d'économie que comprendront les
bons administrateurs landru prenait
alors un aller retour et un aller simple
on allait à la campagne à gand des ou
landru possédait une villa départ et mue
vers une citerne banlieusarde ou dans
une atmosphère de show de tendresse ou
de brûlantes passion on ferait des rêves
d'avenir
la villa de gants des s'avérait
bourgeoise et isolé pour accoupler
l'amour et la solitude et douce bien
chauffés au surplus et ses cheminées et
cette solitude devait faire bientôt
marcher les lentes par la police 20 bien
entendu recherché à granby les disparus
ces onze victimes landru les aurait-il
intérêt après les avoir trucidé et
terrassiers déterrait redevant allende
rue impassible quelques ossements trop
peu au gré des enquêteurs et un soupçon
pris corps landru brûle et il dans sa
petite cuisinière du modèle courant les
restes sanglants de ces épouses
successives
les jeter t-il au brochet le vrai et
qu'on ne trouva rien ou presque
[Musique]
le 7 novembre 21 le procès s'ouvrait à
versailles pour l'édification d'un
public insatiable les journaux
n'hésitèrent devant aucun détail tout le
monde connu la topographie de la salle
d'audience les attitudes de l'accusé les
mouvements de l'accusation les pièces à
conviction ou la cuisinière et le carnet
de dépenses tenait la place d'honneur
onu la pâmoison en plein prétoire de
celle qui n'avait pu faire le voyage de
granby ont dû les pièces noires de moro
giafferi son cri des hypothèses oui des
preuves non et le 30 novembre 21 le
verdict est la condamnation
landru n'avait pas avoué il n'avouera
jamais et monsieur deibler mis le point
final à cette page de la petite histoire
[Musique]
pas que les footballeurs français sont
souvent il ne semble pas qu'il ait
entendu la marseillaise chantée à pleine
gorge par les vingt mille supporteurs
qui se sont rendus à milan sont les
encourager passe encore d'être sourd
d'esprit me pardonne pas c'est d'être
aveugle et maladroit de cette adresse
françois hugues mayot foncé nous en
donne un premier exemple
nous avons des équipes de france face à
une équipe de bulgarie de modeste valeur
pourtant jouent comme des juno
les bulgares eux ont une occasion ils ne
la votent
ce but réveille un peu attaque française
qui s'offre cependant un petit festival
de maladresses on occupe le terrain
adverse mais sans trop savoir quoi faire
on a oublié la marseillaise dans les
tribunes et l'on commence à houspiller
copieusement les joueurs français ce qui
ne les rend pas plus réaliste pour
autant bien au contraire business qui va
nous montrer comment tendanc un but
d'égalisation toof et
vbi connaissent en ligne d'envoyer au
pic l'équipe de france n'ira pas au
chili et au fond après un tel match il
vaut mieux s'en féliciter
[Applaudissements]
m
mitraillages harcèlement mortier c'est
depuis douze jours le lot quotidien
d'elisabeth ville où les troupes
katangaise s'oppose aux assauts des
casques bleus la liste des morts et des
blessés s'allonge à chaque heure
[Musique]
l'hôpital prince léopold at-il ou
n'at-il pas été bombardées par l'onu
messieurs tshombe transigera thil et
reverrons-nous un congo uni chier
[Musique]
à londres il est question de résistance
mais de résistance pacifique 800
adversaires des essais nucléaires ont de
nouveau opposé l'inertie la plus totale
aux responsables de l'ordre et de la
circulation
[Musique]
pour en finir ont décidé d'employer des
méthodes radicales et les policiers
londoniens chargèrent les récalcitrants
dans les cars un par un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici le tango bellamy se préparer aux
joies du ski et à celle non moins
excitante de l'après ski chez lola
prayssac yvette a choisi ce fut la
grosse manche orné de chaînes d'argent
martelé pour marion veracruz tuniques
brodées et plus le rezidor corinne a
préféré se poncho à franges agrémenté
d'une cagoule
marion la chasuble coupe vent sous la
veste bordée de mongolie yvette
emportera cette chasuble tricoter sommet
de cristaux de neige
chez hyacinthe novak isabelle a essayé
mouflon s'être d'hengoat réversible tout
rose doublé de fourrure rose sur une
combinaison de ski rose d'une ligne sans
faiblesse
[Musique]
la ligne est tous dans ses diverses
interprétations de la combinaison de ski
en après-ski gay parce justaucorps de
rési à pompons qui unit à la grâce de
l'hiver la grâce des ballerines
arrêtons jamais vu un après ski du soir
la voici le lan et des belles soirées de
montagne comme en irait-il pas avec le
gie
[Musique]
et de novak toujours cette étrange
parures à cagoule souris sourit d'hôtel
ou chauves souris devant laquelle nul ne
se sentira de glace la montagne madame
comme vous l'a rêvé
[Musique]
policier ou espionnage espionnage ou
policiers il ne meurt pas tous mais tous
en sont frappés en très naturellement
c'est un policier que tous ces hommes et
de toutes les classes lis ce genre de
littérature explique son énorme
production 3 millions de volumes par
mois mais à quoi doit-on la voc d'un
genre hier spécifiquement populaire et
qui conquiert aujourd'hui ses lettres de
noblesse c'est sans doute que pour
l'homme de notre temps la vie à créer
autant de nouvelles servitudes que de
progrès les horaires les réglementations
les tabous l'atmosphère de termitière
organisé où tout est prévu concertée
défini font de lui le prisonnier de sa
ruche pas de place pour l'imprévu et
laventure dans sept vies contrariées par
des rythme trop rapide
l'homme cerner ne trouve plus d'évasion
il n'a plus l'âge de jouer aux indiens
et dans les rues des villes le ciel est
bien plus haut qu ailleurs à l'heure le
roman qui fait un trou bleu dans la vie
l'évasion à la suite d'un héros avec
lequel on change de visage mais un roman
qui dresse dans un paysage dangereux les
signes évidents de la violence et de la
facilité une évasion à la profondeur des
instincts méprisés par le terrible
quotidien
alors l'homme répond il abandonne sa vie
quotidienne pour deux heures il devient
ce héros prestigieux qui fait la loi et
ne la subit plus il se libère de ses
tracas il s'évade il refait sa vie et
c'est pourquoi espionnage ou policier
policiers ou espionnage il leurs deux
heures d'évasion
cette nuit là pendant une heure ou deux
il y a dans les villes comme un silence
il semble que tout soit arrêté désert
vacants à peine si un dernier enfant ça
raid solitaire devant les jouets d'une
vitrine et peut être un clochard
c'est un errant mais un errant de
grandes villes trop exigeants ou sous de
liberté un raté dit-on aussi ou un
flémin tel quel il fait partie du
paysage nocturne
et cette nuit là sans cafard sans
complexe sans doute parce que c'est dans
nos pays une sorte de besoin le clochard
a suivi des rues
[Musique]
cher clochard de la grande nuit de
l'année ondres falote qui passe de
vitrine en vitrine de lumière en lumière
tu sais mieux que tout le monde ce qui
flotte d'impalpable dans cette nuit où
personne n'est seul car il ya dans l
autre chose que des charcutaille et des
boutons cette espèce de minutes unique
où la vérité existe ou labonté à la
portée de la main ou la vie toute vie
trouve un sens où la nuit peut se passer
d'aurore
et c'est ainsi de rue en rue de vitrine
en vitrine de lumière en lumière qu'il
finira comme tout le monde né dans son
univers singulier avec sa tradition de
minuit son réveillon et c'est lumière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
pendant que d'autres à la suite du tout
paris et du tout va limite de presque
fêteront noël au lido avec la nouvelle
revue beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
papa
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]
e
on n'arrive pas à croire qu'un être
humain ait pu délibérément allumé
l'incendié du cirque ambulant denis
terroir la ville jumelle de rio vouant
aux flammes 2500 spectateurs
on reste sans voix devant le bilan de
cette catastrophe sans précédent qui en
quelques minutes a accumulé 360 cadavres
pour la plupart des corps d'enfants sans
discontinuer des volontaires ont apporté
leur sens aux hôpitaux on a multiplié
les transfusions né des 600 blessés
atrocement brûlés combien pourront être
sauvés
au milieu du terrain vague de cinq
goncalo il ne reste maintenant que des
débris carbonisés le grand bain qui
s'est abattue sur la foule le tunnel de
la ménagerie et parmi tous là les fauves
dont la fuite éperdue avait accru
l'ampleur de la tragédie
les éléphants qui ont déchiré la toile
du cirque avait au contraire sauvé des
centaines de malheureux et la girafe qui
tenait la piste au moment du drame la
plus horrible des tragédies
[Musique]
à paris en dépit de l'interdiction de
toute manifestation sur la voie publique
est dictée par le gouvernement certains
syndicats et groupements de gauche
avaient maintenu leur mot d'ordre de
manifestation anti os le défilé de la
bastille à l'hôtel de ville quinze mille
participants dit la préfecture de police
60000 disent les organisateurs lui donc
lieu comme prévu mais il fut marquée par
de violentes bagarres
bil'in de la manifestation plus de 100
blessés
[Musique]
1961 aura été l'année du cosmos le tour
de la terre de gagarine d'abord
l'exploit de titeuf ensuite qui reste à
25 heures dans les espaces de l'air ont
donné à l'urss la gloire d'avoir la
première envoyer un homme dans le ciel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on la première fois des yeux humains ont
pu voir à travers le hublot de la
capsule la terre rouler dans l'infini
pour la première fois des êtres humains
se sont détachés de la pesanteur
originel accomplir ce voyage vertigineux
dont l'idée depuis des siècles trouble
les rêves de l'humanité
et après les deux soviétique deux
américain alan shepard et virgil grissom
ont fait à leur tour le grand bond dans
l'espace
1961 l'année du cosmos mais revenons sur
terre aux états unis john kennedy
démocrate et catholique a succédé
einsenhower républicain et protestants
au brésil quadros a succédé à kubitschek
à la présidence il a depuis abandonné
son fauteuil
au maroc le roi mohamed 5 a succombé à
la suite d'une opération et son fils est
né sous le nom de hassan 2 à st la
couronne
[Musique]
en angleterre la princesse margaret a eu
un fils cinquième dans l'ordre de
succession au trône par contre
l'angleterre a perdu un dominion
l'afrique du sud son leader le docteur
verwaerde a annoncé le retrait de son
payer à la réunion du commonwealth
fidel castro à cuba a résisté
victorieusement à l'assaut des
anticastristes quand un coup sérieux à
la propagande américaine
au congo lumumba prisonnier de ses
adversaires à trouver la mort dans des
conditions mal éclaircies ce qui a
provoqué deux parlements des mêmes à
l'onu une agitation tout à fait tina
plus tu mets dans ce temple général
mangou et à des discussions plus
académique lazio de l'onu au congo même
d'ailleurs n'a pas semblé
particulièrement pacificatrice les
casques bleus se sont heurtés à une
résistance qui a très vite dégénéré en
authentique combat dans cette réparation
congolaise qui dure toujours monsieur da
gama celle de secrétaire général des
nations unies a trouvé la mort à bord de
son avion qui s'est écrasé dans la
brousse
un autre foyer d'incendié s'est allumé
l'angola où les portugais ont réduit la
révolte qui partie justement du congo
tentaient de s'étaler sur le pays
enfin berlin sur la ligne de démarcation
l'est et l'ouest s'affrontent depuis que
le gouvernement de bangkok a fait élever
ce que les berlinois de l'ouest nomme le
mur de la honte
eichmann l'assassin de millions de juifs
récupéré par israël est passé en
jugement mais la sentence de mort qui a
été prononcée est elle bien une peine
pour un tel crime
en france le référendum sur le sort de
l'algérie a approuvé les initiatives du
général de gaulle par une très forte
majorité mais le 22 avril suivant un
putsch éclatent à alger
paris s'est préparée à résister à une
action de force et les rues nocturnes
ont pris un petit air d'état de siège
à ce moment à alger aux cris d' algérie
française la foule a clamé les quatre
généraux qui avait pris la tête du
mouvement de rébellion contre le
gouvernement
mais la fermeté du général de gaulle
devait en quelques jours réprimer le
soulèvement et rendre le calme au pays
ce retour au calme n'est pas allé sans
incident et sur la route de colombey les
deux églises un attentat faillit bien
coûté la vie au président de la
république qui échappe à part une sorte
de miracle
le problème de l'algérie avait fait
quelques pas en avant si la préférence
de lugrin après celle d'evian avec geox
du côté français et belkacem krim du
côté fln n'avait pas apporté de
conclusion on peut croire qu'elles ont
préparé une solution
du côté de be there un coup de tonnerre
la base française de bizerte s'était
trouvée soudain par la seule volonté de
monsieur bourguiba comme assiégée
[Musique]
il fallut devrait condat pour dégager
les accès et rendre à la base sa liberté
drame stupide déclenchée sans raison qui
avait fait 700 morts
chez les paysans un grand mécontentement
trop longtemps alimenté par les
mauvaises conditions du marché éclatait
en violences la bretagne forcé de jeter
ses choux fleurs et ses artichauts faute
de les vendre à des prix rentable
manifesté sa mauvaise humeur
ces barrages de tracteurs sur les routes
faut cette école il devait dans les
semaines suivantes se multiplier dans
diverses régions
[Musique]
par contre les fêtes de l'indépendance
célébrée à dakar marquée entre 13 autres
manifestations semblables le succès de
la générosité française
paris recevait de nombreux hôtes
souverain ou chef d'état il avait
acclamé le roi des belges et la reine
fabiola
et la visite du chah d'iran et de
l'impératrice farah naguère étudiants au
quartier latin faisait frémir toutes les
curiosités et battre tous les cas
du côté sportif les succès répétés de
guy périllat dans les grandes épreuves
de ski internationale ramener en france
des lauriers à envier
dans un autre domaine l'apparition du
twist avait fait l'effet d'un
raz-de-marée
[Musique]
et depuis un certain dimanche les bancs
du palais des sports en savent quelque
chose
le goût de l'art pictural a fait un bond
en avant presque aussi important des
monte-en-l'air de bon goût avec quelques
autres collections dévalisé le musée
d'aix et laissés vides les cimaises
dans le même temps un new york un
rembrandt a battu tous les records de
prix jamais atteint pour un tableau 1
milliards 150 millions d'anciens
enfin diverses inventions sont venus
cette année agrémenter la vie courante
du changement instantanée de caractère
dans les machines à écrire au batteur de
tapis automatique et aux soldats volant
à moteur individuel que de progrès qui
vont faire de notre temps un paradis
terrestre
il ya quand même plus sérieux la france
et l'angleterre penser à construire un
pont sur la manche qui à 70 mètres
au-dessus de la mer donnera passage aux
chemins de fer et aux autoroutes
l'unesco à adopter pour sauver les
temples d'abou simbel menacé de mort par
le barrage d'assouan l'idée de surélever
d'un seul bloc le temple tout entier au
futur niveau des eaux
à orly la nouvelle aérogare la plus
moderne sinon la plus importante du
monde est entré en service balle et
d'acier d'aluminium et de verre ses
dimensions et ses installations laisse
loin derrière elle tout ce qui existait
jusqu'ici en europe
enfin le paquebot france le plus rapide
et le plus luxueux paquebot du monde a
pris la mer et peut-on dire c'est le
chef-d'oeuvre de l'année
[Musique]